este bosque es el frente de criminal y
está todo que es el frente de batalla
más activo que hay en este momento en el
don vas aquí tanto el ejército ruso como
el ucraniano tratan de hacer
contraofensivas para tomar poblaciones y
regiones que son estratégicas para el
uno y para el otro estamos con la
brigada 25 que con estos tanques tratan
de abrir el camino para que la
Infantería ucraniana vuelva a tomar el
control de poblaciones de la región de
Luján
la situación es complicada actualmente
es 50/50 porque el enemigo tiene mucho
poder humano Hace unos días fue incluso
aún más complicado porque las
condiciones climáticas eran muy duras ya
cuando
intentan avanzar y han lanzado todo su
poder en esta dirección como les gusta
decir son el segundo ejército del mundo
Esto hace que cada vez que eliminamos a
un grupo de soldados y sus equipos ellos
envían inmediatamente sus recambios esto
complica la situación y
Ucrania ha asegurado que Rusia espera
lanzar una gran ofensiva con la llegada
de la primavera especialmente en esta
región del Don Vázquez su principal
objetivo militar en este momento por eso
están pidiendo Con urgencia que les den
tanques Especialmente los leopardos
alemanes que son bastante ágiles
la artillería es necesaria pero los
tanques son más maniobrables tienen
mayor blindaje y por eso pueden llevar a
cabo mayores tareas en las batallas en
condiciones de Gran densidad de fuego
son de gran ayuda para que las unidades
de Infantería puedan avanzar y Pedro
los intentos de su parte no paran envían
gente masivamente a morir pero de todas
maneras estaremos de pie hasta el final
ocho años en guerra y muchos de estos
hombres han estado aquí desde entonces
pero coinciden en que nunca antes la
guerra se había sentido con tanta
intensidad